Hello Jenny. How are you today?
Oh, hello Mr Jones.
I'm fine, thank you.
Jenny, let me introduce you to Claire Smith.
Claire will be taking over as shop manager from Carol...
...when she leaves at the end of the month.
Claire, Jenny is one of our three full-time shop assistants.
Pleased to meet you, Jenny.
Pleased to meet you too.
Have you been working here long?
Almost two years now.
I started right after leaving school.
Oh, and this is Simon Thompson, our accountant.
Simon's from Down Under.
How do you do?
Pleased to meet you, Simon.
I've always wanted to visit Australia.
It's a beautiful country.
I'm not gonna disagree.
Claire will be taking over from Carol, who, as you know, will be leaving us soon.
Yes, I've heard a lot about you.
Good things, I hope!
Of course.
Anyway, welcome to Chic Boutique.
I'm sure you'll enjoy working here.
It's a very friendly place.
Yes, I'm really looking forward to getting started.